this episode was supported by brilliant
org hey crazies we have a slight problem
the world we live in the one filled with
things like people animals and cars is
described by something called classical
physics it says the world is predictable
but the tiny world of quantum particles
is inherently random quantum physics
says the world is unpredictable which
leads to one question how can a world
made of unpredictable things be
predictable prepare to have your minds
blown before we get into particles
though let's start with something random
but familiar like a penny
most people consider coins to be pretty
random the reason I like them is because
they only have two states heads or tails
nice and simple if you give it a good
flip you're not gonna have any idea what
state it's in when I just flipped it I
got tails but I could have just as
easily gotten heads let's say I do it 10
times I could end up with any number of
either state totally unpredictable right
well maybe not while I could have gotten
say 10 heads that's not very likely
there's only a 1 in 1024 chance that
will happen the same goes for the
possibility of all tails a 1 in 1024
chance or another way to say that
there's a little less than a point one
percent chance that's what we call a
probability and that probability is much
higher for mixed States which is exactly
what we ended up with for 10 flips even
though each coin flip is unpredictable
we can make some predictions about a
group of flips get a friend because this
is going to take a while
flip your pennies a lot more than 10
times say a thousand times the more
flips you do the closer the group will
tend toward 5050 for a thousand flips
that's about five hundred heads and
about five hundred tails which is an
extremely predictable result and
probably huh
ah see what I did there probably not
that surprising to most of you if you
were to flip the coin a thousand times
again it would probably happen again in
fact there's only a 1 in 10 point 7
Google
google google chance you'll get all
heads or all tails so that's probably
never going to happen
these are things we develop instincts
about its predictable
no one ever expects to get a thousand
heads in a row actually pennies aren't
actually random you're right you're
right he's right
real pennies are not random they're just
very complex
they're only unpredictable because
there's a lot of variables to consider
in fact when my wife and I flipped our
coin we didn't even get 50/50 there was
a slight bias toward tails science
experiments and a whole lotta bomb yo
but here's the thing
I'm not really talking about pennies
pennies are just an analogy for quantum
particles coins have two sides two
states if that coin is perfectly
balanced and perfectly random well then
it behaves exactly like a photon photons
have no rest mass no electric charge and
no color charge just a couple of spin
orientations and that's it they can spin
forward what we call counter clockwise
or right-handed spin or they can spin
backward what we call clockwise or
left-handed spin those are the only
options available so does that mean
circular polarized light is more
fundamental than linear polarized light
yep that's exactly what this means the
two linear orientations are quantum
superpositions of left and right-handed
spin but spin is the fundamental
property of the photon if you've got a
light source like a light bulb then
there's no built-in preference you have
a 50/50 chance of getting either spin
state with each photon just like our
perfect penny although unlike the real
penny our quantum penny I mean photons
isn't really in either state until we
actually measure it it's in one of those
quantum superpositions with a 50% chance
of collapsing into either possibility
when measured that's what true
randomness looks like in the penny
experiment we got to look each time to
see which state the penny was in we
can't actually see the spin of a photon
so we have to send it through a circular
polarizer like these if you have a right
circular polarizer it will pass all
right circular photons and it will block
all left circular photons it's either
passed or it's blocked
no in between each measurement is
individually random but if you do it a
bunch of times like say once for every
one of the ten million trillion photons
coming out of this bulb every second
half of them will pass through and the
other half will be blocked each photon
is random but the whole group is it and
this works for other photon interactions
too we don't know if any one photon will
reflect off of a mirror or get absorbed
but we do know about 84% of them will
reflect and about 16% will get absorbed
it's not even limited to just photons it
works for any quantum particles we call
this the law of large numbers
if you perform an experiment an enormous
ly large number of times the results
will equal the expectation that's
exactly what happens with the universe
everything in it is made of an
unimaginable number of quantum particles
the earth about 10 to the 52 particles
the human body about ten to the
twenty-nine particles a single piece of
dust about 1 million million million
particles a virus about 100 million
particles I think I've made my point
no matter how random an individual
particle is the thing they're made of
will be predictable because of the sheer
number of particles no no no no no no
whoa that was close as usual if you have
any questions please ask in the comments
honestly there was so much I wanted to
talk about in this video I really had to
rein myself in thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy still feeling
like you need some practice with
probability then check out brilliant org
brilliant is a problem-solving website
designed to train you to think like a
scientist on a wide variety of topics
they even have a thorough course on
probability that could really hone your
skills there are questions about coin
flips dice rolls and playing cards all
of which are great analogies for quantum
systems if you find yourself struggling
that's okay making mistakes is often the
best way to learn brilliant even as
Hinson's
solutions to get you into that critical
frame of mind it's a great way to
practice without too much pressure
brilliant was nice enough to sponsor
this video and crazy enough to offer you
a discount the first 72 people that
visit brilliant orbs slash science
asylum will get 20% off an annual
premium subscription it's a really good
offer if you're interested in getting
some extra practice the featured comment
comes from a neuro transmissions who
asked how can the universe have no edge
well there are two possibilities one the
universe is infinite so of course it
doesn't have an edge to the universe is
finite which is a little weirder if you
travel far enough you end up back where
you started anyway thanks for watching